交渉の1
番でしてある川本さんをご紹介いたします。自己紹介お願いいたします。
安証塾の塾長川本です。よろしくお願いします。武道教育の元々ずっと武道やってたんでそれの暗証塾っていうのを作って、ま、
年目なんですが子供たちにこう空手堂だったりとかを教えてます。あと保育士もやってます。
それは使教育論を学ばれてそれを反映させてっていう形です。
ま、もちろんできる範囲でやってますね。
なかなか10
できるとしたら保育園って言ったら
ぐらいしかできないかもしれないですけど色々思考作しながら子供のためにできることはやってます。こ
との出会いははい。2008年、今からま
、17年ぐらい前なんですけど、9月に
先生記念館で政治家の西村信号先生の勉強
会がありまして、いろんな政治だったり
教育だったりのシンポジウムとかこういう
勉強会に当時大学生で参加していて、その
日は西村信吾先生の勉強会にゲストとして
戸塚浩校長が講演されるということで自分
は行ってきました。
その時自分も戸塚校長のことを、ま、全然
知らなくて、なんとなく、ま、イメージで
悪人なんだろうなっていう、ま、自分
なんか子供の教育をしっかりしたいって
思って大学生活を聞てたんで、子供を
いじめる悪い人だと思いながら講演を受け
たんですが、それは全然違くてですね、ま
、自分が漠然と思いた日本人にガッチした
教育というのを実際にやられていて、で、
この理論が全て納得いくもので、そんな方
がいるんだなっていうすごい衝撃を受け
ました。すごい衝撃受けたんで公演会終了
後に自分が挨拶に行って自分は子供たちに
アルバイトとかで武道の誘談者も持ってた
んで子供たちに指導してるものですと
すごい勘明けましたっていうので挨拶に
行きました。
その後手紙も送りまして、秋ぐらいに
じゃあちょっと1回話してみなっていう
ことで東京の事務所へ行ってそこでもお話
を聞かせていただいて実際自分はこの話
だけじゃないに実際の現場っていうの見て
みたいと思ったんですね。
だけではこうかっこいい教育論語ってても実際の現場は違うっていうことやっぱありますのでそしたらこれもじゃ
月の沖縄で合宿するからそこにおいでということで大学
3年生の時だったと思うんですけど
月に凸夫オ夫スクールの沖縄区に初めて見学しに行ったというところですね。
で、それから校長のもで教育論を学ばれるのに何年ぐらいいらっしゃいました?
その後学部を変更してまた
年間大学生活を送っているんですけど、その間にま、何度かと塚愛知の合宿所にも足を運んで現場見させてもらって、教育学科の
年の時に卒業論文でソキャウトスクール論っていうのを書き上げまして、この論文通るのかなと思いながらも、やっぱり大学っていうのはベラルの教授しかいません
から色々あったんですが、なんとか通って就職で、ま、
年卒業の後につけスクールへレシーという形で
4月から行って、ま、2
年間突スクールで事として働かせていただきました。で見られたヨスクの教育論っていうのはいかがでした?う
ん。やっぱり問題時でいいのは普通生活してたらまず会うことないですよね。
で、まさかここまで鉛怠け物なのかとか、
ここまでやっても全然変わんないのか、
これは結構衝撃的でしたね。ちょうど自分
が入った時ぐらいに問題じゃない、普通の
用児を対象にしたジュニアですね、やる
ようになって、それで進歩の差が全く違う
ので問題になってしまった人とこれから
教育を受けて成長していく子たちでは全然
違うんで、そこであ、用事教育って大切な
んだなっていうとこですね。
校長先生は川本さんが
年間合画宿所で生活を共にされて校長の土塚教育を学ばれましたけれども、そういう川本さんに対しての印象はどうでしたか?
うん。あの、ああいう風にきっちりと学んでくというのはね、さすが武ドかよ。リベラルって武ドが嫌いでしょ。戦争に通ずるとかなんとかわけのわからんことばっかり言うよね。
地ヨットスクールでは今幼児にの教育に力を入れてますけれども幼児の教育に力を入れたきっかけというのありますか?
結局昔はこう言っとったんですよ。分かった。来たら
100%直してやる。実際に最初の頃は
100%
直っとったんだ。それがある程度続けて
100%治らんようになっちまった。
なんやろうと思ってよくわからんやったん
やけどもきっと幼児の問題なんだろうなと
は薄うわかる。密後の魂100までって
言うからね。3つまでにある程度の基本が
出来上がるともうその後ずっとダメなんだ
。一ぺ小さいこともやってみるかと。3歳
から8歳までと一応決めて幼児教育をやっ
てみた。驚いたことに3歳でもうダメに
なっとるやつがおるんやね。ということは
3歳以前に問題がある。今度は3歳以前0
歳から3歳までをやってみた。その辺は
まだほとんど良かったな。もうやばいなと
。これこのまま行くとダメになるなと思う
のはいるけど、まだ徹底的にダメになって
なかったよね。で、これが幼児教育をやっ
た理由やね。
1番いかんのはさっき言った進歩。進歩と
いうのは人間の宿命であって進歩し
なけりゃ人間になれない。はただの人だ。
赤ん坊のうちはね、それがどんどん進歩し
て人間という高級なものやね。それになる
んだ。で、それが時々進歩が失敗して仏教
でいう画をたくさん作りすぎるととても
人間とは呼べんような悪いやつが
出来上がるよね。3歳までに正しい進歩の
能力を作ろうやないか。そこで進歩の能力
とは何なの?どういうことをしたら進歩の
能力ができるの?それを極めていきたいの
さ。も大体分かったけど、まだ完璧やない
なと思っとるんよね。これが幼児教育。
びっくりしたのは幼児教育をやっとる時に
知らん教育をしてたんだ。ほで退治教育を
してた子供が生まれてきた時になんとも
普通に生まれた子供より成長しとるわけね
。からこれは大児からやった方が得じゃ
ない。進歩が早いんやからね。それだけだ
からもう大児から教育をするようになった
。
これが今現状です。教育論の幼児教も学ばれたと思うんですけど、それを今どのように使われてらっしゃいます?
自分なんかは例えばこう暗証塾とかでか縮をよくやるんですね。
合宿やって子供世界が出来上がるんで、
それで普通だったらちょっとした喧嘩とか
あったら止めたりすると思うんですけど、
そういうのも止めずに子供同士で解決する
ようにというような場所かそういう風な
ことしたり、あとは武ドか空手だったり
するんですけども、それだけじゃに海を
使ってのトレーニングとかも取り入れて
とにかく本能を鍛えようと生命力を作ろう
というのを第一に考えてプログラムは考え
てます。
説明を鍛えるっていうのは海がいいんですか?
自然がやっぱり1
番怖さもありますし、あと自然だとすぐ変化するんで、その変化に耐える能力もつきますし、自然は
1番いいと思いますね。教育に。
先生、2
日スケルでも海を使って用事を教育しておりますけれども、海の良さというのはどういうこと?
結局ね、本能を作る、本能のトレーニングをするんだけど、
番大事な本能そいつをまず作っておいてやると後の本能は作りやすいできやすい。
番大事な本能は生命力やないか。生きる力。
今度強くするトレーニングを空手に取り入れてらっしゃると言いましたけれども、やっぱり空手のお稽古をする時でもそうやって本を強くするっていうのはいい形で現れますか?
ま、やっぱりそうですね、物しなくなるとか、あとちょっとしたことでも悩まないとかそういうタれ強さは確実に強くなりますよね。精神はい。
肉体的な強さもちろんあるんですけど
教育はねみんな精神なんだよ。体育なんて肉体だと思っとるけど精神なんや。さっきの申しに書いてある通り公然の木を養う方法のを強くする方法正しくはええんだ。
今のは正しいんだけど強くする方法という
のは義を集めて生ずるものにしてという義
。これは正しい行動をずっとやってると
勝手に公然の木が養えるっていう意味やね
。武ドなんていうのは肩をやるじゃん。肩
は義だ。正しい行動。それを繰り返し
繰り返しやるやろ。それから後で今度は
試合になってくる。組み手になってきて
その義を正しく出す。
しょっちゅ型が崩れる。型が崩れたらまた方の練習をして元に戻しておく。それを繰り返すのが常に義を行うっていうのが武ドなんよね。だから本能が強くなっていくの。
小さい子を育ててるお父さんお母さんが悩まれてることたくさんあると思うんですよね。子供が言うことを聞かないとかそうつくとかそういうことに対してのアドバイスってありますか?さん。
うん。あれは特に父親が間違ったことは
間違いだとはっきり言って、ま、やっぱり
お母さんはあまかすってのは分かるんです
よ。この男女の違いてやつで。だから
お父さんはっきりと示す方だ。それが大事
だと思いますね。今叱っちゃいけない
みたいなね、そうだとすごいですけど。ま
、お父さんも叱らないお父さん増やした
もん逆に不安定になるんですよ。
子供が叱られないと自分なんかは、ま、よく叱るんで。それがま、生きすぎるといわゆる適節保育って言われたりまた問題になるんですけども、それ言われる前の範囲内で自分なんかは叱るんで、自分と出会った子供たちってのは罪悪感は身についたんじゃないかなっていう思いはありますね。
[音楽]
の意識があるから罪を犯さない。
悪いことしたら怖い思いするだった不感を味わう。そうするとそれがトラウマになるんで。
だ、トラウマつったらもう全部が全部悪いっていう意味に捉えますけど。いやいや、これは悪いことした時には怖い目に合う。そういうトラウマ。いい意味でのトラウマですね。トラウマを作るために光るんだ。はい。
変なフロイトはやね。トラウマは全て悪い。わざと悪いことをしたりしますよね。
うん。あれはね、悪いことをしたら叱られる。だから分かるようにするのね。分かるように悪いことをする。そうすると叱られる。
叱られたら今の僕を教育しようとしとると
いうことになるん。子供から見ると。だ
からともかく叱られたい。こういうのが
あってね、お父さんが子供男の子2人連れ
てきた。まだ15、歳か34歳か。ほれで
何言ったらもうともかく言うこと期間悪い
ことする。なんとかなるだろうか。なんで
もあんたがなんとかできるんだよ言うて1
つやってみせるからあれしてごらんよ。で
、その子っと暴れ回っとるわけやで。ええ
か、もう1回暴れたら、そのつもりでお
れってそんなもの聞けへんからな。わあっ
と暴れまる。ひつまえてパパーンとこう
羽飛ぶぐらい引ったるんよ。そしたら
うーっとなる怖がって逃げていくんや。
それでえ、父親がびっくりしとる。そんな
ことして、あの大丈夫でしょうかというね
。で、見ててらっ
て喋っとると向こうのな柱の影から子供が
こうやって見とるんや。さっさと逃げれの
にどうしてあんなとこにおると思う。あれ
はね、あの人は僕たちを引ったく叱る。
それはあの人が強いから。強い人は自分
たちを守ってくれる。守ってくれるから
自分たちの存在を示しとかなきゃ。こう
やって自分たちの顔をここにおるぞって
いうことを示しとるに。で、それでも知ら
ん顔しとるとね、そばに来てこうやって
引っ張っとるわ。ツンツン言うてこら言っ
てまたわーっと逃げていく。自分たちが
守らいたい。進歩したい。
それを満たしてくれるのは強い男だからその男に自分たちをはっきりと認識させる。それのテストをするために悪いことをした時に叱ってくれるかどうかを試してるともう
つはどの程度悪いことをしたら叱られるのかそのテストをしとるんだ。
そうすると家庭におけるお父さんの役割りていうのは大きいですね。
大きいよ。今それがなくなっちゃったもんだよな。
いろんな意味でお父さんの役割ができない
ようになったんだけど、その1つにね、
お母さんが強すぎるからっていうのもある
んだ。高電下もう1つはね、母子家庭と
いうのがある。母子家庭の子供がよくうち
に来た。うちに来てそこで叱られて
トレーニングされて親が満足する程度まで
良くなって親が引き取りに来る。その時に
そのお母さんが今後どうしたらいい
でしょう。自信ないわね。ここだからそう
こういう風やけどうちに帰ったらまた元に
戻るんやないか。あんた結婚することや。
そういう正しい結婚相手としていい男では
だめや。強い男を選べ。子供はちゃんと
なるよ。男は必要ないんや。
[音楽]